[Musique]
c'est le premier étage de la fusée
donc c'est pour les jeunes entreprenants
les deux premières années donc
l'incubateur
c'est la première étape
l'incubateur au moment où on définit son
prof de type 1 au moment où on n'a pas
encore rédigé son statut d'entreprise où
on sait pas choisir des talents on sait
pas quels partenaires donc on est là
pour leur apporter bien sûr toutes les
informations sont les maires une
vingtaine d'entrepreneurs où ils
échangent ensemble en plus ils se posent
les mêmes questions
ils ont un animateur en plus ils ont
incuballiance qui est un des
spécialistes français de l'incubation
ils ont des locaux sympathique ça nous a
coûté 23 millions c'est presque un demi
million après de fonctionnement nous
voyons on met le paquet et ils ont
toutes les conditions ils ont un réseau
sur tout un réseau d'entrepreneurs de
très haute qualité
si elle fait vite et d'augurer ici donc
de 51 saclay c'est une et huit zones
mondial d'innovation bien sûr il ya eu
un très bon niveau d'entrepreneurs donc
l'interlocuteur pour eux et même
éventuellement de clients on les met
dans les meilleures conditions pour
accélérer les raccourcir la durée de
création moi j'ai créé mon entreprise en
avait le seul
j'ai eu des difficultés pour déposer un
brevet pour le protéger pour trouver des
fonds pour faire le premier crédit impôt
recherche pour créer une production
un distributeur pour exporter et bien
toutes ces questions là elles sont
concentrés on les aide à raccourcir ce
délai était de 2 3 ans je pense que
c'est un accélérateur vraiment de
croissance pour eux on a une entreprise
sur deux est quasiment qui se casse la
figure dans les cinq premières années
ben là on est là pour les structurer et
bien sûr à accélérer leur réussite les
conforter bien sûr cette réussite sur
des marchés aussi qu'ils sont
une enveloppe croissance donc on
appelait les grandes conditions
donc c'est bien parti et bien sûr on est
passionné par ce problème